[Music]
mom get up I know you're out here
uh-huh I got you now hello boss
you're not dead oh oh I'm sorry to hack
your app to get you out here but she
hung up on me like a hundred times that
was you that was a robo call that really
hurts boss why the hell did you bring me
all the way out here cut uh I think it's
time don't you that's why I'm here
look you know how much I love wasteland
but tormance not out yet and Barthel
still in production oh come on Brian
torments in its final localization and
providers are done with it it's time
they moved on huh maybe you are right
boss this is me have I ever been wrong
Beca buddy real fast let's never speak
of this again
in my defense those people did cut in
line I don't think you know what you're
asking for it's not that simple when the
writing was done for torment the writers
they scattered to the winds if we're
gonna make waistline three happen I'm
gonna have to track them down sounds
like a road trip to me boss
is he Oh find a bus I also happen to be
an expert trucker
hey little help hey someone want to help
me down hello anyone let me guess he
wants us to work on wasteland 3 I don't
have the time Brian got afford to build
and why are you building for it honey
badger season is coming come on you must
have some spare time to work on
wasteland 3 we're gonna have a dialogue
based system this time like torment had
is that right that's right and a more
nuanced storyline and more chances to be
evil and I know you like to be evil evil
I'm in if George's
try not to step in any traps this time I
was just humoring Kevin so he's join us
right reach for the sky
trespassers now robot protect Brian
Fargo whoa stand down at 209 I need my
lead designer Brian what the hell are
you doing here wasteland 3 George I
can't Brian on the lawman now my people
need me you're the one who wouldn't let
me shoot him
look wasteland 3 is gonna have
multiplayer this time you can work with
a friend or you can completely screw
them over by changing the world even if
they're sleeping that's gotta sound
tempting
well screwing over your friends does
sound intriguing how's the art looking
funny you should ask
the visuals have made a huge jump since
wasteland 2 Andre Wallens rejoined us
with his amazing concept pieces the
Bischoff brothers have come aboard and
they're going to work with the NX out
art team we're gonna create a beautiful
post-apocalyptic Colorado well alright
I'm in but only if Colin is in alright
deal you
so why is Karan stealing a boat well
creative leads go a particular kind
crazy when a project finishes Collins
dammit Brian told you on the phone I
have no time to talk I have to set sail
before society collapses textbook
permission to come aboard stay here this
time try not to shoot anything shouldn't
you be at home building a fallout
shelter Brian we're all doomed you know
got red scorpions radiation storms and
if that's not bad enough a Clinton Trump
election we got children a mushroom
cloud got militia night terrors hell
we've got honey badgers Brian look I
want you to come work on wasteland three
ah you seem to be living it you might as
well write about it the only way I'd
even remotely consider this is if all my
unreasonable demands are met you won't
believe how unreasonable unreasonable
try getting divorced a couple of times
the game has to have vehicles with
mounted weapons the player can use in
combat I like that deal I'm not done
has to have the dialogue based system
deeper more nuanced story multiplayer 4k
art support and it has to be set in
Colorado you my friend drive a hard
bargain
deal
haha um one more thing
I get the robot I could use one of those
back home in Detroit that's a deal take
them to Detroit wait what's that now
so are we going to make wasteland 3 now
you know what we're right let's do it
ah didn't I tell you I'm always right
pull up hey Colin hey Bret does uh does
a robot know it's moving to Detroit yet
not to Troy Oh anything but that does
now ease don't make me go there